S
WELCOME ALONG TO WORLD SPORT
LIVE FROM LONDON WITH ME AMANDA
DAVIES.
WITH SOME SERIOUS BREAKING NEWS,
FROM THE WORLD OF GOLF.
AND NOT SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
EXPECTED.
IT WAS JUST A YEAR AGO, YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER, THE FIRST LIV
GOLF EVENT.
WAS HELD, SENDING SHOCKWAVES
THROUGH THE GAME.
SHATTERED LONG HEALTH
STRUCTURES, PARTNERSHIPS, AND
RELATIONSHIPS.
YOU WERE LIV GOLF, OR YOU ARE
NOT.
YOU HAVE, THERE HAS BEEN NO
MIDDLE WAY.
IN A SHOCK ANNOUNCEMENT, ALL
THREE MAJOR GOVERNING BODIES OF
THE SPORT HAVE NOW COME
TOGETHER.
THE U.S. BASED PGA TOUR, THE
YEAR AND BASED DP WORLD TOUR,
AND THE SAUDI-BACKED LIV GOLF
TOUR HAVE ANNOUNCED A LANDMARK
AGREEMENT TO UNIFY THEIR SPORT,
ON A GLOBAL BASIS.
COMING TOGETHER, IN A
COMMERCIAL PARTNERSHIP.
AS THEY PUT IT.
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT LIV
GOLF MEMBERS, SIX TIME MAJOR
WINNER, PHIL MICKELSON, HAS
TWEETED SIMPLY, AWESOME DAY
TODAY.
WITH THE BIG SMILEY FACE.
SO, FOR MORE, WHAT WORLD SPORT
POLLACK, JOHN RIDDELL WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE.
A LOT OF EVENTS OVER THE LAST
12 MONTHS OR SO.
PHIL NICHOLSON IS HAPPY, I MEAN
YOU HAVE TO SAY, IT'S A HUGE
TURNING OF THE TABLES, WHAT DO
WE KNOW ABOUT HOW IT HAS COME
ABOUT, AND WHAT WE ARE SET TO
EXPECT?
>> AMANDA, THIS HAS LITERALLY
DROPPED IN THE LAST 45 MINUTES.
IT HAS TAKEN US ALL OF US BY
SURPRISE.
IT'S TAKEN A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
FOLLOW PROFESSIONAL GOLF AND,
ONLY PROFESSIONAL, GOLF BY
SURPRISE.
DAN JUST TWEETING THAT HE'S
GENUINELY SHOCKED ABOUT THAT.
HE'S GOING TO NEED A MINUTE FOR
HIM TO PROCESS ALL OF THIS,
WHAT IT MEANS.
WHAT ON THE FACE OF IT I THINK
IT'S A WIN FOR GOLF.
I THINK IT HAS BEEN SO
FRACTURED, THE CIVIL WAR THAT
HAS REALLY KICKED OFF, IN THE
LAST YEAR.
AS A RESULT OF THE EMERGENCE OF
LIVE, TURIN REALLY BIG NAMES
THAT THEY'VE SNAGGED, A LOT OF
FAN FAVORITES KIND OF
DISAPPEARED FROM VIEW.
WE SAW AT THE MASTERS, AND THE
PGA CHAMPIONSHIP RECENTLY, SOME
OF THESE GOLFERS ARE STILL
REALLY REALLY GOOD.
REMEMBER AT THE MASTERS WE HAD
NICHOLSON, PATRICK GRIEF, WE
HAD BROOKS KOEPKA, WINNING.
THE GPA CHAMPIONSHIP JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
NOW WE'RE IN THE SKIN BUT, THIS
POSITION, FROM WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND LAW THE PLAYERS THAT
WERE EXILED BY THE WARMER DP
WORLD TOUR, PGA WORLD, TOUR
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ALLOWED TO
NOW REAPPLY TO THOSE TOURS.
ALL PENDING LITIGATION.
WELL IT'S.
FINISHED WE KNOW THE BIG TOURS
WERE SUING EACH OTHER.
LIVE WAS SUING THEM, THEY WERE
SUING LIVE, THE PLAYERS WERE
KIND OF SUING VARIOUS TO.
IT WAS ALL VERY MESSY.
YOU COULD SEE IT WAS TAKING A
TOLL ON SOME OF THESE PLAYERS.
RORY MCILROY, WHO EMERGED AS
THE CONSCIENCE OF MEN'S GOLF,
HE WAS HAILED AND LAUDED FOR
THE STANCE THAT HE TOOK.
HE ADMITTED RECENTLY IT WAS
STARTING TO TAKE A REAL KIND OF
TOLL ON HIS GAME, HE DIDN'T
WANT TO BE TALKING ABOUT IT
ANYMORE.
NOW WE HAVE THE SITUATION WHERE
APPARENTLY THEY'RE ALL GOING TO
COME BACK TOGETHER.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A WIN FOR GOLF,
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW THE
SAUDIS HAVE BEEN PERCEIVED IN
ALL OF THIS.
BECAUSE THEY RECEIVED THEY
REFUSED SPORTS WASHING.
THEY WERE ACCUSED OF USING GOLF
TO FURTHER THEIR OWN AGENDA.
AND NOW THEY ARE IN THIS MIDST,
OF ESTABLISHED LEGACY TOURS.
SOME WILL SAY IT'S A WIN FOR
THE SAUDIS.
>> YES I HAVE THE STATEMENT,
HERE IT IS A LENGTHY ONE.
THERE ARE STATEMENTS FROM ALL
THREE PARTIES, INVOLVED IN
THIS.
THE PGA TOUR COMMISSIONER JAY
MONAHAN, IN PARTS, SAYS THIS.
AFTER TWO YEARS OF DESTRUCTION
AND DESTRUCTION, THIS IS A
HISTORIC DAY FOR THE GAME.
WE ALL KNOW, AND LOVE.
I APPLAUD P I.S., THAT IS THE
PUBLIC INVESTMENT FUND, AND
SAUDI ARABIA FOR HIS VISION AND
COLLABORATIVE AND FORWARD AND
THINKING APPROACH, THAT IS NOT
JUST A SOLUTION TO THE RIFT IN
OUR GAME, BUT ALSO A COMMITMENT
TO TAKING IT TO NEW HEIGHTS.
GIVEN ALL THE OPPOSITION, TO
THIS LIV GOLF SERIES, YOU HAVE
TO SAY, THAT IS A CONCESSION.
DO YOU SEE THAT AS AN ADMISSION
FROM JAY MONAHAN?
ACTUALLY, THEY GOT A WHOLE LOT
RIGHT WITH THE LIV GOLF SERIES.
>> I'M NOT SO SURE WE CAN SEE
IT THAT WAY, WHEN THIS ALL
KICKED OFF LAST, YEAR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE WONDERING IF
ACTUALLY THEY SHOULD HAVE,
COULD HAVE, WOULD HAVE MERGED
AT THAT POINT, PERHAPS THERE
WAS A WAY THEY COULD EVOLVE
PEACEFULLY COEXISTED.
AND AVOIDED ALL OF THIS.
IT DOES NOT, WE'VE GOTTEN TO
THAT POINT, SOME 12 MONTHS
LATER, ALTHOUGH IT WAS A LOT OF
HEARTACHE IN THE MEANTIME.
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW ALL OF
THESE GUYS ALL COME BACK
TOGETHER.
WE'RE GONNA SEE THAT, YOU KNOW,
QUITE POINTEDLY NEXT WEEK.
THERE IS ANOTHER MAJOR COMING
UP U.S. OPEN, IN LOS ANGELES.
I THINK SOME OF THE LIVE
GOLFERS MIGHT BE FEELING RATHER
SMUG AT THE MOMENT.
THEY TOOK ALL THE SWINGS AND
ARROWS, BUT THEY ALSO TOOK A
LOT OF MONEY TO JOIN LIVE.
BUT THEY ENDED UP COMING BACK
INTO THE FOLD ANYWAY.
TENSE, IF NOT HUNDREDS OF
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE PROCESS.
THAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
INTERESTING.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
RYDER CUP?
THE RYDER CUP, PARTICULARLY IN
EUROPE, WHICH IS SUCH A
WELL-LOVED EVENT SEEMS TO HAVE
BEEN BROKEN BY THIS SPLIT.
EUROPEANS HAD TO REPLACE THEIR,
CAPTAIN HENRIK STENSON, WAS
KICKED OFF THE CAPTAINCY AND
REPLACED BY LUKE DONALD.
SOME OF THE ESTABLISHED
VETERANS OF THE EUROPEAN TEAM,
LIKE LUCY WESTFORD, TOLD HE
COULD NEVER PLAY FOR THE
EUROPEAN TEAM AGAIN.
DOES THIS MEAN THEY COULD BE
INVOLVED?
AGAIN THE RYDER CUP IS FIXED?
A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD CERTAINLY
HOPE SO.
BUT WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT
EXACTLY THIS IS GONNA PLAY, OUT
WHAT IT ALL MEANS.
BUT CERTAINLY IF YOU ARE
GOLFING, AND YOU LOVE SEEING
THE BEST PLAYERS IN THE WORLD
COMPLETING, IN THE SAME COURSE
IN THE SAME, TIME THIS IS GOOD
NEWS.
>> DON, STAY WITH US BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED LAW BRIAN CATER,
ICK I KNOW FRIEND OF WORLD
SPORTS, BROAD CASTER OF MANY
YEARS, I'M DELIGHTED TO SAY HE
NOW JOINS US ON THE PHONE.
BRIAN, MY FIRST QUESTION TO YOU,
WE'RE ALL PRETTY STUNNED IN THE
STUDIO BY THIS NEWS, WHAT IS
YOUR REACTION?
>> I AM STUNNED AS WELL.
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS GONNA BE A
PRETTY RANDOM NORMAL TUESDAY,
JUST ONE OF THOSE DAYS, LUCKILY
IN THE WORLD OF SPORTS,
EVERYTHING WE DO IS A LITTLE
BIT LESS IMPORTANT THAN THE
REST.
IT'S GOOD.
MY PHONE GOES UP, AND IT'S THIS
NEWS.
SO YES, STUNNED IS THE EXACT
RIGHT WORD.
>> THERE HAS BEEN MUCH OF A
DISCUSSION, ALREADY ABOUT WHO
IS THE BIGGEST WINNER FROM
THIS.
DO YOU KNOW, DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN BEHIND
THIS WHO WAS PUSHING FOR?
IT WHO DOES IT BENEFIT THE MOST?
>> I AGREE WITH DON, I'M GLAD
HE JUST SAID IT BECAUSE I
COMMEND THIS FROM A FAN
STANDPOINT.
AS A GOLF ANNOUNCER, TALK SHOW
HOST, PLAY-BY-PLAY HOST.
WE ARE SERVICING THE FANS.
I OBVIOUSLY PLAY THIS GAME.
SO MANY OTHERS PLAYED THIS
GAME.
THAT'S ONE THING THAT SEPARATES
THIS GAME FROM THE, OTHERS WE
PLAY IT.
WE WANT THE OTHER SPORTS, MAYBE
WE PLAY THEM WHEN WE WERE A KID,
BUT THIS IS A GAME FOR A
LIFETIME.
SO YOUR FANDOM RUNS A LITTLE
BIT DEEPER.
THE FANS ARE GOING TO BE HAPPY.
WHAT THE FANS GETS?
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE ALL THE
DETAILS, BUT WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE
THE FANS ARE GONNA, GET MORE OF
THE BEST PLAYERS PLAYING
TOGETHER AT THE SAME TIME.
THAT IMMEDIATELY SEEMS TO BE
LIKE THE WINNER.
I DON'T KNOW IF I AGREE THAT
THERE IS A CLEAR WINNER, AND A
LOSER, WITH THE REST OF THEM.
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE REST OF
THE DETAILS.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE QUICK TO
SAY, TOUR LOST ON THIS, I'M NOT
SO SURE ABOUT THAT.
AS LONG AS THE FANS WIN, THAT'S
ALL THAT I REALLY CARE ABOUT.
>> THE FANS OF COURSE, GO TO
THESE EVENTS WATCH THESE EVENTS,
BECAUSE OF THE PLAYERS.
THERE HAS NO DOUBT BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE LIFT THAT HAS FORMED
OVER THE LAST 12:24 MONTHS
WITHIN THE LOCKER ROOM WHETHER
YOU'RE ON THE SIDE OF RORY
MCILROY AND TIGER WOODS.
OR THE SIDE OF THE LIKES OF
PHIL MICKELSON.
HOW BROKEN DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
HOW EASY WILL IT BE FOR THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS TO BE REPAIRED?
>> I THINK MOST OF THEM WEREN'T
THAT BROKEN.
MOST OF THEM WILL BE REPAIRED
EASILY.
I THINK THAT'S A HECK OF A
QUESTION, I THINK WE SAW THAT,
GO BACK TO TUESDAY OF THE
MASTERS.
DON AND I TALKING, WERE BOTH
SURPRISED THAT RORY AND BROOKS
WERE DOING A PRACTICE ROUND
TOGETHER.
THAT WASN'T MANDATED, THEY JUST
DECIDED TO.
AND THEY KNEW THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY GOING TO CAUSE MORE
QUESTIONS, AND ACTUALLY MAKE
THEIR LIVES MORE COMPLICATED.
SO I THINK YOU HAVE MORE OF
THAT, THEN YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE.
I THINK MOST OF THE FANS, MOST
OF THE PLAYERS, ARE JUST HAPPY
TO HAVE THIS GO AWAY.
GO BACK TO THE OPEN
CHAMPIONSHIP.
CAN HE WIN, IF HE BEATS, RORY
WITH RUMORS SWIRLING ABOUT
WHETHER CAM SMITH WAS LEAVING
OR NOT.
THAT FELT LIKE A LOSS, IF YOU
ARE ROOTING FOR THE PGA TOUR
TEAM.
THEN, YOU HAD TO FEEL LIKE THE
EXACT OPPOSITE, WHEN BROOKS
POPPED UP A LEAD IN THE
MASTERS.
THE HAD TO FEEL LIKE A LOSS,
AND THEN IT GOES BACK TO THE
EXACT OPPOSITE WAY AT THE PGA
CHAMPIONSHIP.
WE'RE GOLF ENDS.
MAJOR CHAMPIONSHIPS ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO FEEL LIKE A LOSS TO
US.
WELL THERE'S ALWAYS HISTORY
SOMETHING TO ROOT.
FOR THESE LAST THREE WE'VE HAD
HAVE HAD A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE FANDOMS LOSSES.
GOLF HAS NEVER FELT LIKE THAT
BEFORE.
AND I'M GLAD THAT IT WON'T FEEL
LIKE THAT ANYMORE.
>> I SUSPECT IS NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY JUST YET GIVEN THOUGH WE
ARE IN THE FINAL BUILDUP FOR
NEXT WEEK'S U.S. OPEN I THINK A
WHOLE LOT OF PLAYERS ARE GOING
TO BE ASKED A WHOLE LOT OF
QUESTIONS PLENTY M